merci beaucoup de nous avoir rejoint ce
matin et d'être notre invité politique
vous êtes ministre délégué des Outre-mer
merci d'avoir été avec nous on a
beaucoup de sujets à aborder ce matin on
commence par le 10 mai puisque ce 10 mai
marque la journée de commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavage une cérémonie
aura lieu cet après-midi dans les
jardins du Luxembourg mais une cérémonie
j'ai envie de dire à minima le président
de la République est absent la première
ministre à la mais ne prononcera pas de
discours est-ce que c'est regrettable
regardez pas l'intensité de ce qui fait
quoi le président de la République a été
à fort-de-fou j'y étais c'est le premier
qui va c'est le premier qui reconnaît
que le combat contre l'esclavage est
parti des esclaves eux-mêmes voilà il
faut reconnaître la vérité il a été à
Fort de jouer il a fait un discours je
crois assez puissant les gens étaient
très émus il a été hier et j'étais un
peu la même veine à Lyon au fort de
Montluc il faut arrêter de dire il faut
que le président fasse aussi fasse cela
ce qu'il a fait dès cette année
quelque chose au gouvernement je le
constate juste pour dire que je constate
fort de joue c'est un élément
extrêmement fort c'est la première fois
qu'un président dans l'histoire qu'un
président de la République dit
explicitement
c'est eux qui se sont levés c'est eux
qui ont gagné la République a reconnu
derrière voilà c'est ça qui se passe et
l'idée les messages qu'il a passé hier
je connais parfaitement mon Luc pour
différentes raisons je trouve ça
extrêmement fort extrêmement fort après
c'est le
sur ce 10 mai alors il y a plusieurs
dates
il y a le 10 mai il y a le 23 mai et
puis après c'est dans chaque territoire
le 22 mai le 270280110 juin 9 octobre le
20 décembre à la Réunion Mayotte a
choisi après une date qui rassemble mais
toutes les dates rassemble si on veut
bien essayer de se rassembler c'est la
République qui rassemble
ce qui menace notre République c'est
l'individualisme c'est le
communautarisme est-ce que sur des dates
comme ça comme l'a fait le président de
la République on peut dire d'où est
parti la révolte elle est partie de tout
ça l'ouverture le reconnaître et
derrière on se rassemble il y en a marre
de se diviser
on va parler des sujets évidemment
concerne les premières ils sont nombreux
à commencer par le pouvoir d'achat comme
en métropole évidemment qui est une
préoccupation majeure est-ce que la vie
quotidienne n'est plus dure aujourd'hui
dans les outre-mer qu'en métropole avec
un mot c'est que l'inflation il est plus
faible qu'en métropole que les sens il
est plus faible que nous avons décidé
avec le gouvernement de ne pas appliquer
la réforme du chômage que l'électricité
y est plafonnée les efforts sont
considérables donc la vie
d'aller vers le meilleur c'est toujours
un combat permanent c'est un combat
permanent on a réformé ce qu'a effet
Victorin là sur le bqp on fait le bqp
plus qui maintenant c'est une bonne
nouvelle je viens d'avoir une lettre de
Monsieur Saad que j'avais fait macgm qui
me confirme que la réduction de 750
euros par conteneur s'applique jusqu'à
la fin de l'année tout ça c'est pas de
l'argent qui vient d'ailleurs mais c'est
c'est des efforts considérables je
m'élève contre l'idée l'inflation est
exponentielle première c'est un mensonge
alors voilà mais c'est un mensonge
absolu puisque
l'inflation il est plus faible mais elle
s'attaque cette inflation à des
populations qui ont un niveau de vie
plus faible et donc il faut agir plus
avoir d'autres mesures pour les aider à
lutter contre les inflation
cette annonce de Monsieur Sade qu'il va
bien voulu me faire
je prends par exemple le prix de l'eau à
Mayotte qui est bloqué lui aussi peu à
peu je prends par exemple à la Réunion
ou le bouclier
décupait plus c'est un peuple chaque
préfet comme consigne avant c'était une
fois par an
tout au long de l'année on engrange hein
ce qui fait que l'inflation baisse et
que l'emploi se crée
je comprends bien que c'est mieux quand
c'est moins cher que gratuit mais ça
n'existe pas ça ça n'existe pas le vrai
sujet c'est de se rassembler comme on le
fait pour le dîner sur l'esclavage c'est
de rassembler contre la vie chère c'est
de se rassembler sur l'eau j'entendais
Victoria murène sur l'eau en Guadeloupe
petit mensonge pourquoi parce qu'on n'a
jamais fait autant parce qu'on en a
jamais fait autant qui c'est qui paye le
fonctionnement du syndicat c'est l'état
quand il y a trois mois on a mis le SMIC
c'était une bonne chose c'était une
bonne on s'est rassemblé président
chalut le président
osba
Francis et puis on s'est dit allez on le
fait ensemble on arrête hein on le fait
en sorte et on met un programme tous les
ans sur trois ans l'argent qu'il faut
quand il y a 3 mois on réparé deux
fuites par jour on est monté à 36 pas
mal d'ailleurs on entend moins crier
puisqu'on parle de l'eau alors il y a
les questions effectivement sur les
fuites d'eau les entretiens des
canalisations mais aussi des inquiétudes
sur la sécheresse sur le truc que Macron
pas encore su faire pleuvoir il se
déplace il pleut
donc ça veut dire quoi
c'est la vie ce qu'il faut c'est prendre
il faut mettre en place comme un Mayotte
une usine de dessalement il faut
travailler comme on le fait partout à
aller chercher de l'eau des
osmoseurs comme on dit vous dites
collectivités qu'elle doit aussi se
prendre
et on le fait ensemble comment on est en
train de le faire Mayotte comment on est
en train de le faire en Guadeloupe c'est
ça qui se passe comment on est en train
de le faire à la réunion avec la
sécurisation de la de l'amener d'eau
ils ont pas pleuré dans la vie il faut
travailler il faut agir et surtout se
dire la vérité et le faire ensemble se
dire la vérité et le faire ensemble
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
il y a une coopération suffisante je
pense très très bien on revient juste à
une question du pouvoir d'achat puisque
hier lors des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement le député la France
insoumise de Martinique Jean-Philippe
Niort a posé la question sur le prix des
billets d'avion disons que le prix des
billets d'avion avait augmenté de 50% en
Martinique et en Guadeloupe qu'est-ce
que vous répondez à ça est-ce que des
mesures vont être prises la première
mesure à prendre ce qui est des avions
excusez-moi si l'état de met pas 130
millions sur la table il y a plus
d'avion sur sur la Réunion et je le fais
en toute amitié et en toute coopération
avec Huguette Bello
on a mis sur la
Guadeloupe 120 ou 130 millions il y a 2
ans on se prépare en remettre au temps
le premier sujet c'est ça j'ajoute
du billet d'avion sur la Guadeloupe il
faut faire entre Wallis et Futuna il
faut faire la décerter
de Guyane il faut faire la desserte de
Miquelon il faut faire la desserte de
Saint-Martin donc chacun regarde
l'ensemble du sujet donc premier sujet
on dépense des centaines de millions par
an à ce que les compagnies existent que
les compagnies là au moins il y aura
plus de prix d'avion si on pouvait
regarder ça et se dire cette vérité
deuxième vérité ne nous concentrons pas
sur un sujet l'État intervient et
soutient toutes les décertes intérieurs
ce qu'on appelle la double insularité et
ça dépend des dizaines de millions après
on est sur
le sujet la desserte qui intéresse
quand tout le monde parle entre la
France et les Antilles entre la France
et antique
qui a fait augmenter le prix des sens et
le monde qui est comme ça et donc face à
ça il faut réagir il faut réagir donc on
a changé les structures de la Dom le
Parlement a voté un complément on est en
train de travailler pour avoir plus
d'argent sur la DOME changer la règle de
la Dom tout ça ça se fait pas c'est ce
qu'il va y avoir des mesures pour aider
les
ultramarins à ce que le prix du bien du
billet du billet d'avion baisse en tout
cas où on doit financer le prix du
billet d'avion soit vous faites baisser
le prix du billet d'avion la réponse est
non soit vous donnez les moyens pour
avoir un billet d'avion enfin le travail
pour les gens c'est la réforme de la Dom
qui est en cours je veux doubler son
budget c'est déjà 100 millions quand
même la Dom c'est déjà 100 millions si
on prend tout ensemble et vous souhaitez
doubler le budget et je souhaite doubler
bouger avec l'aide des collectivités
locales avec l'aide en prendre le
Parlement on va lui demander des choses
madame la Première ministre dans le
débat budgétaire qui se construit en ce
moment c'est un des sujet s sur lesquels
j'allais dire elle est favorable à ce
que je propose c'est à dire que le coût
du billet d'avion pour les ultramarins
pourrai baisser à quelle échéance
normalement je suis pas que l'échéance
parce qu'il y a des lois il y a des etc
on fait tout pour augmenter le budget la
DOM et que le billet baisse
on va parler de vos différents
déplacements demain nous accompagner
elisabethez pas mais d'abord demain vous
accompagnez Elisabeth borne ce soir à La
Réunion un déplacement de trois jours si
je me trompe pas qui doit faire le point
sur une consultation engagée depuis
septembre avec les élus
ultramarins quel est l'objet précis de
se déplacement
vous n'avez pas juste pour une chose ça
n'existe pas
j'imagine moi je suis content que Madame
première ministre
ils prennent bien la sensibilité aussi
quand vous déplacez outre-mer c'est pas
pareil que quand vous lisez un dossier
il vient de le vivre 4 jours j'ai fait
déjà 19 déplacements je pars à la
Réunion ce soir quand je rentre lundi je
pars en Guyane puis j'irai à
Saint-Martin puis j'irai en Calédonie
donc voilà donc sentir les choses c'est
comme ça qu'on avance c'est quand le
premier sujet c'est d'avancer on est sur
la réunion sur la réunion des problèmes
d'agriculture c'est clair un problème de
pêche avec des sillons qu'on n'arrive
pas à faire prendre à la Commission
européenne qui qui nous bloque on a le
grand projet des élus réunionnais à qui
le rappelle le ferroviaire j'appelle pas
le ferroviaire un transport sur
l'ensemble de l'île ou
on discute bien on a à peu près d'accord
sur ce qui a à faire dans les années qui
viennent les trois ans qui viennent avec
madame la Présidente il y a tout ce que
fait monsieur Melchior sur la santé
la santé La Réunion est un département
en pointe sur la santé on va le
constater est-ce qu'on peut de temps en
temps aller se réjouir de ce qui se
passe
à la Réunion
en rentrant outre-mer
est-ce que les élus attendent c'est
qu'on progresse surtout les sujets
ensemble ce dieu la vérité est
progresser ensemble c'est journaliste
qui veulent des annonces
les deux les deux j'imagine vous revenez
de Saint-Pierre et Miquelon vous nous
l'avez dit
si les remontées que vous avez eu des
attentes les inquiétudes oui les
inquiétudes partagées on s'est dit c'est
un voyage quatre jours je crois personne
est resté 4 jours un discours vérité on
a fait des réunions de travail non le
premier sujet
de Saint-Pierre-et-Miquelon c'est sa
démographie
et sa démographie il y a 27 naissances
programmées jusqu'à la fin de l'année un
programme est prévu et au 1er mai il y
avait eu déjà 31 décès
ce qui est en cause c'est à terme si on
bouge pas c'est ce qu'on s'est dit
ensemble
l'existence même de l'archipel c'est
menacé parce que s'il y a plus personne
une fois que vous aurez 400 habitants
c'est fini plus ils sont tous vieux
les jeunes il faut qu'il trouve
l'existence même de cet archipel
aujourd'hui la démographie
et on a pris conscience qu'il fallait se
retrousser arrêter de se disputer
travailler ensemble après chez Diabaté
sur les la pêche il y a deux il y a deux
Avenières économiques vous avez la pêche
vous allez le tourisme voilà donc on n'a
pas parlé de la desserte de champion à
Miquelon
partout il y a des choses partout on
dépense des millions d'euros des
millions d'euros
autre territoire la Polynésie où les
indépendantistes ont remporté les
élections territoriales donc on
Polynésie française il dispose pour la
première fois d'une majorité absolue
pour gouverner c'est aujourd'hui que
doit être élu la présidence du futur
gouvernement comment vous allez
travailler avec cette majorité
je connais bien Monsieur botterson je
voudrais saluer d'ailleurs l'équipe qui
est partie qui n'a pas gagné les
élections il y a un changement de
générations il y a un changement de
génération il y a une prégnance de la
question sociale
je note les déclarations de Monsieur
bretonne qui d'abord ont construit
d'abord en travail donc on n'a pas
d'états vous allez vous rendre
prochainement Polynésie je veux venir ça
se construit ça dépend c'est un sujet
important donc le ministre d'intérieur
Gérald Darmanin
on discute ensemble
Polynésie
à la vitesse où je me déplace ça devient
compliqué oui il y aura un déplacement
Polynésie c'est clair les yeux au carré
il faut les préparer mais quand avant
l'été après l'été mon emploi du temps
est un peu de cassette
qu'est-ce que vous avez vu dans ce vote
dans ce vote dans cette victoire claire
des indépendantistes est-ce que vous y
avez vu une forme de rejet de défiance
envers la métropole
pas du tout j'ai vu des élections
locales et on se bretonne a bien pris
soin de ne pas dire si un vote pour
l'indépendance élections locales avec
une majorité qui était là depuis très
longtemps donc des jeunes une question
sociale c'est ça que j'ai vu voilà mais
quand même est-ce que du coup ils ne
sont pas en position de force pour
négocier avec l'État un référendum
d'autodétermination
vous n'êtes pas inquiet pour vous la
Polynésie française ne deviendra pas
indépendante
la vie la vie est à la vie est un long
fleuve pas très tranquille mais c'est
surtout une vie de travail une vie de
travail et je sais que je bretonne a
envie de travailler mais pour vous il ne
demandera pas l'indépendance de la
polynamisme pas tout de suite chez moi
je crois que les gens la
Polynésie française ça représente une
très très grande partie de l'espace
maritime français est-ce que il y a un
risque d'une perte d'influence de la
France
président de la République et une
stratégie Indo-Pacifique claire
vous savez j'étais en Calédonie en
88 ou 88 c'est ça
on dit à l'époque il fallait lutter les
Calédoniens disaient y compris kanak il
faut lutter contre les Australiens tout
ça c'est des le monde est confronté une
crise diplomatique une crise écologique
une crise migratoire considérable
considérable le vrai sujet c'est que la
République puisse rassembler l'ensemble
des populations qui la composent
pour lutter pour trouver les bonnes
solutions les bonnes solutions à cette
crise qui est mondiale arrêtons de nous
regarder le nombril cette crise elle est
mondiale je pense que sur la Polynésie
pour la Calédonie d'une perte
d'influence de la France et de viser
peut-être de la Chine sur cette terre
je suis inquiet dire je suis inquiet ça
ne suffit pas
ce qu'il faut faire c'est travailler
c'est ce que propose
de la Chine sur ces territoires
franchement
en se dire la vérité ensemble et
progresser ce qui compte c'est le niveau
de vie des gens ce qui compte c'est que
les gens soient bien dans les
territoires ce qui compte c'est que les
gens soient bien dans la République
et je suis pas sûr que ce qui disent oui
oui que les communautaristes
indépendantistes soient majoritaires
polynésien qu'est-ce que vous leur dites
je leur dis travaillons ensemble ce qui
compte c'est le bien-être des
Polynésiens ce qui compte c'est
l'influence de la Polynésie dans la
République et l'influence de la
Polynésie républicaine dans le monde
la Nouvelle-Calédonie puisque vous en
parliez il y a un mois Elisabeth borne à
rouvert à Matignon les discussions sur
l'avenir institutionnel de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie elle a reçu les
indépendantistes et les profs France une
visite de votre part et de celle de la
part de Gérald Darmanin était annoncé
pour le mois de mai qu'elle aura lieu
elle aura lieu au 1er juin 1er juin vous
irez et je note que Monsieur ma poule
président de
est à Paris il a rencontré la première
Mini il a rencontré Gérald Darmanin je
l'ai rencontré
travaillons travaillons c'est vrai que
c'est pas très
Inn de dire voilà moi je suis contre les
annonces des machins travaillant sur le
en Guadeloupe on a travaillé et ça s'est
arrangé et c'est vrai peut-être j'ai pas
fait assez de publicité pour dire que
l'État paye beaucoup mais ça n'a pas
d'intérêt ce qui compte c'est d'avoir de
l'eau et sur la Nouvelle-Calédonie les
relations sont désormais apaisées entre
l'exécutif et les indépendantistes il me
semble que je parle correctement le
monsieur Mapou a été reçu par Gérald
Darmanin longuement par la première
ministre enfin moi il a vu le président
du Sénat il a vu le président de
l'Assemblée nationale la président de
l'Assemblée nationale on peut dire qu'un
accord vous paraît possible pour quand à
quelle échéance là aussi vous êtes
terrible c'est le temps dans le
Pacifique et pas le même que le vôtre
pas le même que le mien ce qui compte
c'est
d'asseoir tout ça d'asseoir tout ça et
qu'on progresse pas à pas le temps
pacifique et pas du tout le même il y a
donc vous irez le premier juin vous nous
l'annoncez et il y a aussi une visite
d'Emmanuel Macron cet été qui avait été
envisagé à ce qu'elle aura lieu je ne
commande pas les décisions du président
de la République donc
c'est pas ce que j'ai dit
un mot sur Mayotte également un Mayotte
ou le gouvernement a donc lancé une
opération pour lutter contre la
délinquance et l'immigration illégale on
expulsant massivement des étrangers en
situation régulière principalement venu
des Comores où on est cette opération
aujourd'hui
il y a trois sujets il y a l'opération
d'aller arrêter quelques délinquants
des vrais voyous qui coupe des mains qui
attaquent des enfants
c'est quand même ça le vrai sujet à tous
ceux qui critiquent je veux dire allez
voir le banditisme absolu et si on le
faisait pas on dirait là vous l'avez pas
fait on le fait à la la vous le faites
ça suffit il fallait le faire et Gérald
Darmanin il courage de le faire deuxième
sujet le décalage est-ce que vous
accepteriez vous
que je peux vous habituer que partout il
y a des bidonvilles qui se mettent
machin etc ce qui est fait j'ai eu un
échange de messages avec une de mes
anciennes collaboratrices qui est
responsable de l'hébergement d'urgence
elle m'a dit on n'a jamais fait autant
pour reloger pour loger elle m'a dit
c'est un boulot émouvant mais c'est
terrible on nous a donné tous les moyens
pour reloger tous les moyens je rappelle
qu'on a réouvert en société HLM avec
Action Logement ça va être un progrès et
non et puis après il y a tous ceux qui
sont là de nature irrégulière
en jouant c'est pas la France
bon déjà des réunions hier avec la mise
à faire étrangères ni de l'intérieur des
deux des deux pays si j'ose dire et les
deux présidents de la République qui ont
échangé est-ce que les Comores vont
accepter de reprendre leur
ressortissants je pense que oui oui je
pense que oui que ça va se faire
doucement
tout ça est toujours compliqué je pense
que oui et que le bon sens va l'emporter
et le bon sens c'est quand même que la
France coopère avec les Comores
et que les Comores coopèrent avec la
France
quelle est cette histoire de rejet de
ces ressortissants de ses propres
ressortissants
donc vous leur dites il faut les
reprendre sinon quoi sinon il faudra
suspendre l'aide au développement qui
est accordé au Comores je pense que je
ne suis pas envie que j'aime pas quand
on fait chanter ma République
donc oui donc oui donc suspension de
développement suspension
je note que tous les ministres ont la
double nationalité beaucoup beaucoup
donc voilà essayons
sur les trois sujets il y en a un qui
très bien parti c'est d'arrêter des
assassins il y en a un qui est bien
parti aussi c'est de recazer de
construire et mieux reloger les gens il
y en a un qui est en discussion et je
pense qu'il est en bonne voie elle
prendra en fin de compte cette opération
c'est une accélération ce qu'on veut
avant bon elle durera pas on pourra pas
maintenir les forces de l'ordre quand on
aura abouti à un certain nombre de
d'arrestations de voyous c'est ça que je
veux mettre en avant
de trois mois oui deux trois mois
Elisabeth borne veut finalement un texte
immigration en juillet elle a demandé à
Gérald Darmanin de travailler dessus
pour cet échéance est-ce qu'il y aura
dans ce texte un durcissement du droit
du sol à Mayotte je m'occupe pas
d'immigration ça avec géraldarin on a
partagé
des tâches sur les sujets immigration
c'est complètement lui ça se concerne
pas que l'outre-mer
ce texte est-ce que vous savez que
l'immigration à Cayenne
quelle est la première nationalité qui
est mis à Cayenne
ce sont des Marocains sahraoui et la
deuxième c'est des séries à la troisième
c'est des Afghans le monde change
le droit du sol à Mayotte je pense que
oui mais c'est pas ma compétence
un mot sur les travaux du Sénat puisque
la délégation sénatoriale aux outre-mer
a remis ses travaux sur l'avenir
institutionnel des Outre-mer est-ce que
vous êtes favorable à un changement de
constitution pour renforcer la
différenciation le président de la
République à la suite de l'appel de
Fort-de-France a réuni tout le monde 7
septembre
il a indiqué sa voix donc j'y travaille
moi je m'a demandé de travailler sur les
perspectives alors conditionnelles et
pas mal fait d'ailleurs
vous allez reprendre certaines de leurs
propositions
en tout cas leur plan dans la note que
je fais je fais une note à Monsieur
ministre de l'Intérieur que j'espère lui
remettre 15 juin puis il sera transmise
au président de la République et il
décidera vous savez dans la vie
qu'est-ce que vous allez reprendre dans
la vie il faut dire des choses réalistes
en tout cas quand vous êtes ministre
c'est pas des invocations c'est pas des
évocations
c'est dire des choses réalistes
susceptibles d'être faite voilà et je
rappelle que si elle est modifications
institutionnelles fortes mais il faut
l'accord des populations
mais vous n'êtes pas fermé un changement
de Constitution n'est pas fermé du tout
quel président de la République a
indiqué clairement il propose aussi que
chaque année au Parlement soit consacré
une semaine législative aux outre-mer
c'est peut-être 37 heures à 18h enfin
j'en sais rien c'est pas le sujet un
dernier
mot il ne Pen a fait des scores élevés
la dernière présidentielle dans les
territoires d'outre-mer est-ce que ça ça
a acte un échec de la politique
d'Emmanuel Macron dans ses territoires
je rappelle que je suis marrant comme
vous posez la question c'est pas la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron c'est
éventuellement la politique du
gouvernement conduite par orientée par
Monsieur Macron la politique des élus
locaux la politique des chefs
d'entreprise
arrêtez de tout personnifier comme ça au
pouvoir quand vous êtes au pouvoir en
fait pas tout ce que vous voulez c'est
pas une dictature c'est pas une
dictature pour que ça marche
c'est un échec global du travail mais
bien sûr mais bien sûr exécutif
et chez tout le monde est-ce qu'on peut
on réussira ensemble
nos communautarisme des élus locaux face
à l'état non commutarine de l'État face
aux élus les chefs d'entreprise c'est ça
qui s'est passé et c'est ça que le
président Macron Darmanin essaye de le
changer une dernière question que poser
Victorin Lurel qui était à votre place
et qui était votre prédécesseur
ministère des Outre-mer est-ce que vous
avez les moyens de votre politique
aujourd'hui
jamais le budget de l'outre-mer n'a été
aussi fort il a dépassé les trois
milliards jamais le budget de l'État
consacré à l'Outre-mer qui est à 23 24
milliards n'étaient aussi élevés ça
c'est la vérité personne ne veut le dire
ça gêne ce qu'il pleure merci
Jean-François caranco merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité pour la
première fois de cette émission dans
cette émission merci d'être venu et on
passe aussi sur le club des territoires